un joint dans la rue cela pourrait
désormais vous coûter cher depuis ce
matin ce geste est puni d'une amende de
200 euros
et si vous payez tout de suite 145 euros
mais à condition d'être pris en flagrant
délit par les policiers une mesure dont
on parle depuis 2018 qui était en
expérimentation depuis le mois de juin
dernier dans quatre villes de france
c'était une promesse de campagne du
président emmanuel macron mais les
policiers ont tout notre regard sur
cette question pourquoi il faut
s'attaquer aux trafiquants pour cela il
n'ya qu'une solution il ya qu un passage
obligé
ces grands fonds c'est en moyens humains
et en moyens matériels le faste qui gère
les stupéfiants aux antilles guyane
maintenant cette mesure nous permet
quand même d'apporter une réponse
effectivement une sanction qui est
d'ordre pécuniaire à quelqu'un qui a
commis un délit parce que bien souvent
des petites procédures et et fait
effectivement sans doute encombrer les
tribunaux
alors il sache si vous voulez ça se
solder par des simplement par des
rappels à la loi mais là il faut savoir
que les billets sont maintenant risque
quand même une amende de 200 euros
minorée 150 euros majorée à 450 euros au
palais du sist discours est le même chez
les magistrats
il estime que contrairement à ce qui a
été annoncé que cette mesure ne va pas d
engranger des tribunaux que nombreux
sont les drogués qui n'auront pas les
moyens de payer ces 200 euros et que les
magistrats ne prononce pas de peine à
l'encontre des consommateurs de cannabis
mais préconise des soins ça fait bien
longtemps qu'on ne poursuit plus le
strict toxicomanes
l'idée c'est plutôt de les orienter vers
les structures de soins
donc les tribunaux sont pas aujourd'hui
chargé par des procédures des usages de
stupéfiant sans doute que le
gouvernement a voulu soutenir une
politique d'affichage qui consiste à
dire on va nous aujourd'hui verbaliser
et donc régler la question de la
consommation par le biais d'une amende
forfaitaire mais encore une fois nous
nos syndicats on n'est pas
ne pense pas que ça va régler quoi que
ce soit ça risque peut-être à l'année je
n'ai pas de chiffres mais ça ça va
rester à la marge ça sera une trentaine
de procédures compterait travaux
tribunal et qui sera traité par les
commissariats mais ça ne réglera pas la
question de la dépendance parce que
quelqu'un qui consomment ce pas une
amende de 200 euros qui va régler la
question
les représentants du syndicat de la
magistrature font également remarquer
que cette amende forfaitaire ne
s'applique pas aux mineurs que la france
est le premier consommateur de cannabis
en europe et qu'il est le pays qui a la
politique la plus répressive
la solution pour eux une meilleure
politique de prévention et une meilleure
prise en charge des utilisateurs de
drogues